bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans europe
hebdo nous sommes comme d'habitude au
parlement européen et dans cette
émission nous allons parler des lobbys
ces groupes de pression qui
interviennent à tous les niveaux du
processus de décision ici au parlement
européen comment mieux les encadrer
c'est ce que nous verrons avec notre
invité est d'abord la question
d'actualité l'austérité et elle bientôt
fini pour la première fois la commission
européenne lâche du lest sur la rigueur
la politique d'austérité un temps ses
limites parole de josé manuel barroso
président de la commission européenne
le chantre de la discipline budgétaire
estime que pour réussir une politique
doit avoir un minimum de soutien
politique et sociale déclarations faites
hors caméra mais le message est bien
passé de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent
en europe contre la politique
d'austérité généralisé le fonds
monétaire international plaide lui aussi
pour une modération des mesures de
rigueur même son de cloche à washington
jack loup nouveau secrétaire américain
au trésor presse l'europe de desserrer
l'étau pour ne pas aggraver la crise en
moyenne la dette souveraine des pays de
la zone euro atteint plus de 90 % de la
richesse du jamais vu sur le continent
qui compte par ailleurs 20 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi devant cette
situation intenable six pays réclament
un délai pour ramener leur déficit sous
la barre des 3% limite autorisée par le
pacte de stabilité
parmi eux la france les pays-bas ou
encore la belgique al'inverse
l'allemagne elle maintient le cap
affichant une bonne santé économique qui
exaspère ses partenaires aujourd'hui la
rigueur défendu par berlin ne semble
plus efficace alors l'austérité en
europe c'est bientôt fini
retour à bruxelles au parlement européen
un député européen nous a rejoints
robert rochefort bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau pour
commenter l'actualité européenne chargée
alors vous êtes députés français élus du
modem et vous êtes économiste vous avez
été président notamment du credoc
l'austérité ne semble plus faire recette
en europe puisque même le président de
la commission européenne estime qu'il
est temps d'en de ralentir le rythme sur
les politiques de rigueur qui
s'appliquent sur le continent est ce que
pour vous ces paroles annonce un
changement de cap en europe c'est
vraiment étrange ces petites phrases
surtout dans la bouche de monsieur
barroso il est sûr que ce qu'a fait
l'europe avec des pays comme la grèce
par exemple c'est pas bien comment dire
le type d'austérité qui était imposé au
peuple grec le peuple grec n'arrive pas
à s'en remettre et alors là maintenant
par une sorte de petite phrase on a
l'air de distiller l'hypothèse qu'il y à
une autre politique a presque envie de
dire qu'entre monsieur barroso et puis
monsieur montebourg ou madame lienemann
en france il pourrait presque y avoir la
même chose évidemment tout ça n'a pas de
sens si vous comprenez qu'il s'est
trompé non mais attendez attendez la
question n'est pas là la rigueur il n'y
a pas d'alternative à la rigueur
j'entendais dans le sujet qu'on vient de
voir on rappelle que la dette atteint 90
et même 95 % en france et qu'elle va
dépasser les 100% qu'il faudra bien et
ça donne n'est pas tenable et on ne peut
pas continuer à croître en revanche ce
qui est vrai c'est que ça n'a pas de
sens de ne faire que de la rigueur
tendance austérité sans avoir en même
temps des initiatives de croissance et
de relance alors saisir cet été ça tombe
bien qu ici on soit à bruxelles où on
aurait pu être à strasbourg les
initiatives de croissance elles doivent
pour l'essentiel venir pour ce qui est
des grands programmes de l'europe
l'europe doit doit relancer les choses
l'europe doit relancer des grands
programmes et doit avoir une politique
coopérative et non plus une politique
très concurrentiel je vous cite juste un
exemple pour que ce soit très concret il
faut que alstom en france et siemens en
allemagne arrivent à s'entendre pour
coordonner leurs efforts pour faire un
tgv européen de l'avenir qu'on puisse
vendre au reste du monde un peu comme on
l'a fait avec airbus il ya quelques
décennies vous pensez que l'allemagne
est prête à faire alors pour l'instant
de nom pour l'instant non et c'est bien
ça la difficulté l'allemagne d'abord
mais comme préalable que justement on ne
soit pas ambigu sur la rigueur et qu'on
reste sur la logique de la rigueur et je
la comprends d'une certaine façon et
puis il ya une autre question qui est
plus embêtant qu'avec l'allemagne c'est
que on pourrait se dire que l'allemagne
devrait aussi voir son intérêt parce que
l'allemagne n'est pas intérêt à voir des
pays autour d'elle qu'ils soient en
situation économique mauvaise passe ils
font partie d'une même zone mais il se
trouve que l'allemagne exporte beaucoup
vers l'asie exporte de plus en plus vers
l'asie et peut-être considère tels que
la priorité un peu comme peugeot par
exemple pour ses voitures la priorité
est de soigner ses exportations vers
l'asie et vers la chine est un peu moins
de jouer la coopération en europe si
c'était le cas ce serait très embêtant
est ce qu elle peut se retrouver isolé
parce qu'il ya quand même des appels
beaucoup d'appels pour pour ralentir le
rythme de la dollar à l'heure alors en
europe on peut pas rester isolé
éternellement surtout quand on est un
leader et la france de ce point de vue
va évidemment avoir un rôle absolument
fondamental à jouer qui va être de
trouver des situations intermédiaires
mais il faut savoir de quoi on parle il
faut être extrêmement concret s'il
s'agit de dire il faut un peu plus de
temps pour arriver aux 3% bon je crois
que à peu près tout le monde aujourd'hui
reconnaît que c'est pas absolument
dramatique
si en revanche il s'agit de dire comme
on dit là que le temps pour arriver aux
3% on peut signer la fin de la récré
austérité et recommencer à faire de la
dépense publique à tout va et n'importe
comment évidemment c'est absurde et
l'allemagne aura raison de dire non
alors comment vous jugez la stratégie de
la france notamment son programme de
stabilité économique le gouvernement a
transmis récemment la commission
européenne est-ce que la feuille de
route présentée par paris et crédible
pour vous écouter et à l est elle est
comment dire elle tient compte à la fois
de la situation économique elle tient
compte des exigences nouvelles de
coordination des politiques en europe
donc ça on ne peut pas le nier en
revanche est ce qu'elle est convaincante
pas complètement bon on nous annonce
pour l'année prochaine des économies de
dépenses publiques et sans vraiment dire
comment et ça c'est toujours le problème
en france est en fait la façon dont on
va faire ces économies de dépenses
publiques ça va être très important vous
voyez que par exemple si on arrête
toutes les dépenses d'investissement de
la puissance publique parce que c'est le
plus facile d'arrêter les dépenses
d'investissement on coule encore plus la
conjoncture économique donc si on fait
les efforts défensifs les dépenses mais
en tout cas il faut faire des efforts
sur les dépenses de fonctionnement passe
aux dépenses d'investissement
or là c'est le plus difficile et puis
alors vous me permettrez de dire que
dans les prévisions que la france a
envoyé à bruxelles il ya encore et
j'allais dire comme d'habitude et comme
nicolas sarkozy est comme françois
hollande l'avait fait lors de la
campagne présidentielle l'année dernière
ce que françois bayrou n'avait pas fait
il ya un pari de la croissance qui est
pas censé les prévisions de
monsieur moscovici pour bruxelles de la
semaine dernière 10 à partir de 2015
2016 2017 on va faire 2 % c'est
oppressant frère françois moi je vous
dis un jour d'aujourd'hui le quoi je
vous dis au jour d'aujourd'hui que si on
ne fait pas plus de réformes de
structure si on ne se modernise pas
davantage eh bien on ne fera pas ses 2 %
de croissance et évidemment ce sera
problématique parce que ça veut dire que
le chômage aura du mal à diminuer avec
l'activité économique aura du mal à
repartir mais je ne crois pas que par un
coup de baguette magique en espérant que
la croissance du monde soit meilleur que
la croissance viennent mieux relance aux
états unis je ne crois pas pour
l'instant assez 2% de croissance en 2015
2016 2017 et vous voyez bien que du coup
comme toujours parce que la croissance
c'est quelque chose qui réduit les
déficits mais comme la croissance n'est
pas là bas les déficits se réduisent pas
tout seul eh bien merci robert rochefort
de nous avoir décrypté cette actualité
européenne
actualité aussi dominé par la situation
en italie le pays traverse toujours une
zone de turbulences fortes parce qu'elle
n'a toujours pas de gouvernement
en attendant le président sortant de le
président la république sortant giorgio
napolitano a été reconduit à la tête du
pays florilège des télévisions
européennes
des applaudissements en parlement
italien après six tours de scrutin le
pays à enfin un nouveau président à
bientôt 88 ans giorgio napolitano avait
pourtant très clairement écarté l'idée
d'un deuxième mandat mais ce samedi il a
ressenti l'obligation ce sont ses
propres mots d'offrir la disponibilité
qu'on lui réclame
giorgio napolitano parviendra-t-il à
sortir l'italie de sa crise politique
le président de la république a été
réélu pour un second mandat de sept ans
samedi dernier après moult débats 0
bandit semant
d'audio napolitano et le premier
président italien qui se succède à
lui-même il a commencé sa journée en
signant une lettre de démission de ses
fonctions qu'il assumait depuis le 15
mai 2006 un septennat qui se termine un
autre qui commence
la politique ne comptait pas
se représenter il
souhaite prendre une retraite qui le dit
mais gars mérité et presque à
contrecoeur qui l'a accepté de rempiler
pour un second mandat qu en fait les
partis politiques qui ont un fils tu es
aujourd'hui qui sont allés le chercher
et qu'il lui a demandé de la chrétienne
second mandat
de bien me ward allait tous nous devons
tous avoir à l'esprit à présent comme
j'ai tâché le faire ces derniers temps à
la cites la situation difficile avec les
problèmes de l'italie et des italiens et
l'image mahb le rôle international de
nos
surprises
alors pour tenter de comprendre cette
situation italienne complexe nous sommes
avec un journaliste italien david
carretta bonjour bonjour 7 correspondant
pour à bruxelles pour la radio radio l'a
dit khaled
radio nationale italienne
giorgio napolitano n'est pas forcément
très connu en france il se succède donc
à lui même une question simple est-ce
qu'il a le pouvoir de débloquer la
situation dans laquelle l'italie se
trouve formellement non parce que le
président de la république en italie a
des fonctions surtout symbolique mais
quand il a été réélu par une grande
majorité il ya eu un accord entre
monsieur napolitano et les grands partis
les partis traditionnels
sa réélection est lié à la formation
d'un nouveau gouvernement
monsieur napolitano va nommer un premier
ministre est normalement normalement
parce que l'italie c'est un petit peu le
ko en ce moment normalement les grands
partis et celui de monsieur berlusconi
et celui de monsieur belles salles et
donc la droite la gauche et le centre de
monsieur monde qui vont soutenir ce
gouvernement mais il faut attendre il
faut voir parce que on a vu deux mois
d'un emballement de la politique
italienne et on sait pas ce qui va ce
réellement passé au parlement
aujourd'hui l'italie est divisée en
trois forces politiques c'est ça est-ce
que si l italie avait eu le même système
électoral que la france par exemple les
choses auraient pu être autrement se
présenter autrement c'est possible
en italie on a un système très compliqué
qui donnent une majorité à la chambre
aux partis qui prend même un une voix de
plus que les autres partis mais au sénat
n'ont donc cela complique les choses on
aurait besoin probablement d'un système
majoritaire ou comme en france où comme
en angleterre on l'a eue pendant
quelques temps ça a bien marché mais on
a changé la loi pour faire plaisir à
certains grands partis il ya donc celui
d'un silvio berlusconi absolument
absolument mais il ya un problème
aujourd'hui à monsieur grillo avec ce
mouvement 5 étoiles du mouvement de
stijl qui a eu 25 % c'est un mouvement
de rébellion nous non contre l'austérité
de l'europe mais plutôt contre la classe
politique et avec un système français
par exemple le résultat pourrait être
d'une révolte électorale contre les
partis traditionnels va être plus
important si c'est possible est-ce que
la situation actuelle fait le jeu de
silvio berlusconi oui certainement si
lorsqu'on était politiquement mort en
novembre 2011 quand il l'a il a été
contraint de démissionner avec l'entrée
au gouvernement de monsieur monde
d'ailleurs c'est giorgio napolitano le
président qui a obtenu sa démission plus
fort de la crise de la dette absolument
avec beaucoup de pression internationale
de la part de la france de l'allemagne
mais lorsqu'elle était mort
politiquement même un an après même en
novembre 2012 parce que son parti dans
les sondages étaient à 15 16%
on disait que la gauche italienne
devrait aller au pouvoir parce que elle
était crédible en fait l'a démontré dans
les derniers 2 -
pas seulement sa faiblesse électorale
mais surtout le fait qu'elle n'est pas
fiable la gauche italienne un tu peux
comme le ps en france est très divisé et
il n'y a pas une ligne politique on l'a
vu avec l'élection du président de la
république parce que les deux premiers
candidats étaient deux candidats de la
gauche qui ont été votées par la ddt
même par la droite au moins monsieur
marini mais c'est la gauche qui a trahi
une partie de la gauche qui a trahi
les accords l'italie c'est quand même la
troisième puissance économique de la
zone euro est ce que la situation
politique actuelle peut avoir des
conséquences importantes sur la
stabilité économique est ce que l'italie
peut être menacée demain à nouveau sur
les marchés je ne sais pas parce que les
marchés sont en train de se calmer au
niveau général en ce moment donc ils
vont laisser tranquille et l'italie pour
on l'espère nous les italiens au moins
que je croie aussi les européens c'est
vrai que l'italie est systémique s'il ya
un problème en italie si les marchés
commencent à nouveau à douter de la
capacité de l'italie de repayer sa dette
ça va être un gros gros gros problème
pour la zone euro mais on attend la
formation éventuellement d'un
gouvernement en italie merci beaucoup
david carretta pour cette analyse cette
émission se poursuit françois beaudonnet
recevra dans un instant corinne lepage
pour parler des lobbys les groupes
d'intérêt qui sont enregistrés ici au
parlement européen en tout cas sur le
papier en réalité leur influence est
très forte elle se manifeste jusque dans
la rédaction des textes européens vous
allez le voir avec ce sujet de thibault
le floch et véronique en deuil fini
cet homme peut rentrer sans problème au
parlement européen pourtant ce n'est pas
un homme politique non alain berger et
lobbyistes une profession dont l'image
est sulfureuse en france mais beaucoup
moins à bruxelles c'est assez commun ici
oui je suis un lobbyiste pour un groupe
français qui est le groupe alstom et
dont ça ne me choque pas c'est quelque
chose qui dans le langage anglo saxons
où dans le monde anglo saxon pas ça fait
bien
il n'y a pas de raison d'imaginer qu'on
doit aller se cacher dans un bistrot sur
la place jourdan pour influencer de
façon malhonnête un député ont fait on
va simplement apporter de l'information
à quelqu'un qui en a besoin et qui
ensuite prend des décisions sur la base
de l'ensemble des informations qu'il a
pu recevoir pas la peine de se cacher
d'autant qu'il n'y aurait certainement
pas assez de café à bruxelles pour
accueillir tous les lobbyistes
plus de 2500 structure de lobbying ont
des bureaux dans la ville entre 15 et 27
mille représentants d'intérêts privés il
travaillerait chaque semaine ce qui fait
de bruxelles la deuxième place mondiale
derrière washington et ça ce n'est pas
nouveau
les lobbyistes ont poussé la porte du
parlement dans le milieu des années 80
jacques delors créé le marché intérieur
européen
avec l'aide de grands industriels du
continent dont les recommandations sont
largement reprises par le président de
la commission européenne une armée de
lobbyistes investi les institutions
bruxelloises dans les années 90 il n'en
ressortiront pas
face à cette montée en puissance en 2008
sim kallas vice-président de la
commission européenne a une idée créer
un registre de la transparence pour les
lobbys c'est
cette liste est consultable en quelques
clics plus de 5600 organisations de
lobbying ils sont inscrits on y trouve
air france le géant de la chimie bayer
ou bien encore alstom sur la page de la
compagnie on y retrouve notre lobbyistes
alain berger son entreprise déclare
entre 250000 et 300000 euros annuels
rien qu'en lobbying un chiffre
conséquent mais qui n'est pas surprenant
pour les géants industriels présents à
bruxelles qui inondent les
parlementaires de rapports et de
préconisations
il ne nous appartient pas de prendre des
décisions c'est le politique qui
prennent les décisions après mais ils
ont besoin d'être informés qu'on
convenablement pour prendre leur
décision c'est pas parce qu alstom dit
qu'il faut pas aller au delà de telles
limites ou tel règlement qu'il faut que
le législateur prenne ça pour argent
comptant
pourtant selon certaines organisations
qui luttent contre l'influencé des
lobbyistes à bruxelles les représentants
des groupes d'intérêts hot rod influence
sur les parlementaires européens le site
lobby plague s'est penché sur un projet
de loi relatifs à la protection des
données des citoyens européens de
nombreux amendements ne sont que des
copier coller de rapports écrits par
ebay ou amazon 1re copiage qui n'étonne
pas florence autret journaliste
économique à bruxelles et spécialiste
des lobbys ses bananes si vous voulez le
gard à voir le député il lui dit écoutez
là franchement nous ça nous pose un
énorme problème il faudra ajouter
absolument ces trois lignes dans le
texte est-ce que vous pouvez vous en
charger bah oui le gars il va tabler
l'amant mots si certains députés
acceptent de reprendre tel quel les
propositions des lobbys ce n'est pas
tant par malhonnêteté que par manque de
moyens exemple dans le secteur bancaire
un domaine sur lequel travaillent 40
fonctionnaires face à eux les banques
ont engagé plus d'une centaines de
lobbyistes vous avez 40 gares à la dg
marché intérieur face à
je ne sais pas peut-être 150 lobbies
très bien payé beaucoup mieux payés que
les gens de la commission donc comment
s'est créé la réglementation dans ces
conditions en fait elle ce qu écrit
entre l'industrie et la commission ce
qui veut pas dire que l'industrie dicte
ses conditions
parce qu'il ya des conflits très
violents et des négociations très dures
mais mais c'est fatal surtout sur ces
sujets là qui a une forme de
j'allais presque dire de cogestion
decaux législation
quasiment pas un projet de loi n'échappe
aux lobbyistes ce qui pose un problème
car leur travail n'est pas de vrai pour
l'intérêt général mais pour celui de
leurs clients
alors nous sommes en plateau avec
corinne lepage bonjour bonjour vous êtes
députée européenne française vous êtes
membre du groupe des démocrates et des
libéraux on va dire en gros c'est le
sens ici aussi au parlement européen et
vous êtes membre de la commission santé
et sécurité alimentaire en ce qui
concerne on vient de le voir dans ce
sujet de thibault le floch les les
lobbys ça fait des années qu'on sait
qu'il faudrait faire des choses ici on
sait que ce registre ce fameux registre
dont on a parlé dans le reportage n'est
pas efficace puisqu'il est basé sur sur
le volontariat qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire selon vous pour que cela change
enfin je pense qu'il ya des choses à
faire au niveau global enregistre
obligatoire par exemple et ne laisser
entrer que les gens régulièrement
enregistrés je pense que des mesures que
les députés peuvent prendre en ce qui me
concerne j'ai beaucoup réfléchi au sujet
parce que c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse
depuis 25 ans et lorsque je suis arrivé
en 2009 j'ai décidé que tous mes rendez
vous serez public c'est à dire que je
publie sur mon site internet la liste
des intérêts économiques et des ong des
restes que je reçois je ne dis pas ce
qu'il me dise ça je considère ça fait
partie de la providence réalité mais en
revanche
les rencontres son public c'est une
manière de mettre cartes sur table ne
sait pas les lobbys en eux-mêmes qui
pose un problème parce que
les normal lorsque vous êtes un député
de vous être informés et si une
entreprise a choisi de vous informer
vient le biz plutôt que directement par
ses dirigeants après tout c'est son
choix ça n'a pas d'importance condition
qu'on sache à qui on parle de ce soit
clair ce qui n'est pas acceptable c'est
des experts indépendants qui ne le sont
pas c'est à dire qu'ils sont des faux
nez de l'aube des lobbyistes c'est pas
possible alors vous êtes donc vous le
disiez ici depuis 2009 on a vu dans le
reportage pas entre un lobbies d'alstom
les choses sont très claires j'ai envie
de dire il arrive avec son badge alstom
est ce que vous vous avez été surprise
est ce que vous avez été approché au
cours de ces dernières années par des
lobbyistes qui ne disent pas leur nom
non parce que je fais très attention que
mon équipe
d'assistant est extrêmement vigilante
sur ce point et donc nous ne recevons
que les gens dont nous savons exactement
qui y sont et avec un pedigree précis
parce que des tentatives coûteux y en a
peut-être mais c'est même pas venue
jusqu'à moi mes assistants régler le
problème en amont encore une fois je
vois les lobbystes le problème c'est pas
très longue liste bon c'est les faux nez
et puis c'est des députés qui sont trop
sensibles
aux lobbies notamment d'origine
industrielle nous avons au sein du
parlement nous le savons tous un certain
nombre de députés qui reprennent quasi
systématiquement les amendements qui
leur sont préparés je me dirais même pas
proposé mets préparés par les lobbyistes
et ça je trouve que c'est pas normal ça
c'est courant on l'a vu dans le
reportage cd temps un copié collé tout
le temps tout va mais oui parce que
c'est très facile de se rendre compte
parce que je suis une destinataire comme
d'autres de propositions d'amendements
quand je vois tel ou tel collègue qui
les reprend une extension je sais
exactement d'où ça vient et ça on peut
pas faire quelque chose contre ça que
voulez-vous faire c'est aussi un
problème de conscience et de
responsabilité de chacun des deux chacun
des députés puis peut-être aussi de la
presse d'être un peu attentive à cela et
si un ou deux députés se faisait
épingler précisément pour avoir fait ça
je pense que ça disent les autres ne le
ferai plus il ya eu quelques années ici
justement des journalistes britanniques
qui avaient piégé comme ça un certain
nombre de députés européens certains
sont passés d'ailleurs en justice dans
leur pays est-ce que vous pensez que le
problème de la corruption est ici là
nous sommes au coeur du parlement
européen à bruxelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est un problème répandu
c'est très difficile de répondre à votre
question qu'il existe j'en suis
convaincu j'en suis convaincu
j'ai vu par exemple lorsque nous avons
voté le texte sur l'étiquetage
alimentaire où nous voulions un certain
nombre à avoir un étiquetage très simple
pour que chacun d'entre nous
consommateurs on puisse voir tout de
suite si et beaucoup de sel pas beaucoup
de celles beaucoup dessus pas beaucoup
de sucre donc c'était ce qu'on appelait
le traffic light c'est à dire orange je
me ferai comme des feux tricolores
c'était très simple et bien on il est
dit que j'ai pas vérifié l'industrie
agroalimentaire avait dépensé un
milliard d'euros pour faire capoter
cette opération qui a capoté donc les
lobbyistes ont bien travaillé mais les
députés les ont bien écouté et c'est ça
le problème alors on parle beaucoup de
transparence en france actuellement ici
les députés européens dont vous vous
devez mettre sur votre page ici de
parlementaires donc ces publics mais les
déclarations
d'intérêts oui moi j'ai été voir pour un
certain nombre de députés français
autres la plupart du temps il n'y a
quasiment rien de marqué garder la
mienne elle est très plein c'est une
feuille une feuille a4 qui est scanné
est ce qu'il ya des contrôles pour ça
est ce que certains disent que non
puisque l'un d'entre nous a dit qu'ils
représentent et le monde la terre le
ciel ou je ne sais quoi et personne ne
lui a rien dit en ce qui me concerne je
fais cette déclaration de manière très
sérieuse
parce que je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important et j'ai déclaré y
compris les associations auxquelles je
peut appartenir sans toucher un centime
et c'est pas seulement une question
d'argent c'est pas seulement un intérêt
financier non non je ne crois pas je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin que
cela je vais vous donner un exemple là
encore qui m'est personnelle et personne
n'avait rien demandé j'ai créé il ya 15
ans
une association qui s'appelle depuis
gênes qui s'occupe de gm eh bien lorsque
j'ai été nommé rapporteur du parlement
européen j'ai démissionné de mes
fonctions de présidente du criigen parce
qu'on peut pas faire les deux parce que
personne n'avait rien demandé mais je
trouvais que c'était pas bien que dit on
peut logiquement se poser un problème en
fait ce que vous nous dites là depuis le
début de cet entretien c'est qu'en fait
vous avez été plus loin que ce que
demande le parlement européen en matière
de pensée bien sûr et je prendrai
beaucoup d'autres pourraient le faire et
ce qu'il faudrait pas là aussi que ce
soit obligatoire moi je pense que oui de
la même manière l'utilisation de nos
fonds parlementaires j'ai une page son
mât mon site que chacun peut aller
consulter sur laquelle qui s'appelle en
toute transparence où je détaille usages
que je vais des fonds que j'ai en dehors
de mon salaire qui est indiquée
usages que je fais pour les déplacements
l'enveloppent de des assistants
parlementaires etc tout ça est précisé
je trouve que c'est normal donc vous
connaissez bien également la vie
politique française on parle beaucoup
des lobis il à bruxelles mais les lobbys
existe ici également son mari jean
prisca pire en francs alors est ce que
c'est quelle comparaison vous faites
entre les deux j'aime encore mieux ici
où c'est un peu explicite et qu'en
france où c'est totalement quasiment
secret et où il n'y a quasiment aucun
contrôle et où les experts indépendants
sont légion et ça c'est absolument
insupportable
donc il faudrait également agir oui côté
france je pense que sur le sujet de la
transparence en france les vrais sujets
sont pas ceux dont on parle les vrais
sujets c'est effectivement les conflits
d'intérêts mais conflits d'intérêts eux
pas seulement pour les parlementaires
mais de tout ce qui les entoure et c'est
dès que la question du financement des
partis politiques mais ça c'est un sujet
tabou dont personne ne veut parler mais
il est au coeur du débat en réalité
merci beaucoup corinne lepage d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'avoir parlé
avec nous de ce dont on parle beaucoup
ici c'est à dire des lobbys c'est la fin
d'europe hebdo on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec kathia gilder d'ici là
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires